there is a lot that you probably missed
in this chapter because Hunter Hunter is
back to one of my personal favorite
things which is lengthy explanations of
abilities being applied through very
stringent rules but underneath all of
that there is some big stuff happening
and also we have a very big announcement
because one of togashi's assistants has
confirmed exactly how many more chapters
we can expect and I'll tell you right
now it is much better news than I ever
could have hoped for so I'm gonna do the
shameful YouTube thing and just sort of
leave that lingering for a bit because
we need to get into this chapter so
they're very aggressively because it's
that good so the Phantom troop flashback
is now over which in some ways I think
is a bit of a shame I was looking
forward to that maybe one last step to
take us right up to the kurter events
but I do have to say I'm quite satisfied
for now one because it leaves a lot of
their actions there in the unknown zone
for us to draw our own conclusions and
two because the flashback may not
necessarily be over here the Phantom
Trooper currently chopped up into all
sorts of groups and we may well be
telling their full story within those
fragmented groups but for right now we
are back into Haley hunting season and
I've seen that a few people are a bit
confused by what's happening right now
with the room and the door and the dudes
and the everything God this is so much
of the stuff so just quickly The Troop
busted through a wall and entered the
room through the back toilet after that
feitan and the unnamed guy exited the
room through the doorway but then when
the guy re-entered the room through that
same doorway he vanished poor he was
teleported away so Nobunaga designates
this as a landmine type nenability which
to my understanding is a direct
application of Aura to a very specific
area in this case being the doorway and
this type of ability is so or intensive
that it's estimated that a user could
only place two to three landmines at
once what I found really interesting was
the fact that it only works one way if
you're already in the room then yeah
yeah you can live through the doorway
because it only triggers if you enter
the room through the door although
assumedly the nen user could plant the
landmines and switch it to the other way
around but in case you've forgotten or
just didn't pay attention either is fine
this landmine ability belongs to Haley
member for Conte who looks like a really
nice guy but he's currently a level 26
meaning that he's murdered 26 people the
Conte is also an emitter which is very
important because his ability it takes
us all the way back to the days of nov
traditionally nov has been identified as
a conjurer and that's because the
official Data Book labels him as such so
I I can understand where that impression
comes from however in this case we prove
that that information is just as
unreliable as always because tagashi
himself very recently classified nov as
nimita in the memo for his exhibition
but both nov and vacante's abilities
follow very similar principles of
teleportation and restricted travel
between rooms the key difference is that
nov nov is an absolute boss and just
admitted his own nen Mansion whereas
vacante isn't in scrub and is just using
existing rooms although as we discover
at the end he's also potentially using a
room crafted by the abilities of other
members of the Hayley family and we know
this because in chapter 394 terebellum
which is which is this guy yes he has a
name yes I know it yes I've commissioned
my artist to make custom art of him it's
it's just the state of my life right now
but Tara rebellum flat out and stated
that vacante was connecting two
different rooms together so the way I
now like to think of a Conte is like a
budget knob which is still very
dangerous by the way nov's abilities
were exceptionally overpowered and even
having access to a much watered down
version of that gives the hilly family a
shocking degree of Versatility a lot of
this opening section also features a
very classic tagashi trademark which is
the whole characters speculating on
abilities or events that the readers
already have the answers to because
we've known the old man's conjuration
and the vicante's doorway powers are two
separate things we've known that for
quite a long time in fact we knew that
before this whole room mini Arc began so
we spend a lot of time with finx and
obanaka arguing it out and coming to
their own personal conclusions which I
always find interesting because from a
purely storytelling perspective it's
quite an inefficient way to do things
because we as readers know from the
get-go that thinks is just flat out
wrong so it can feel a bit redundant and
or pointless to dive into his thoughts
and see all of the Mind diagrams and the
hypothesis it's definitely not lean
storytelling and I could definitely see
some people designating this as like a
bit of a waste of panels however me
personally I really like seeing these
characters showing they're working and
then still coming to the right
conclusion often in narratives I think
characters are just given the advantage
of knowing stuff instantly that the
readers know or figuring it out
instantly because it just saves time and
having to repeat steps that we already
have gotten to and yeah that's great for
streamlining the story and such but
togashi's approach makes these
characters feel so much more real and of
course the ultimate point of having this
nanny argument was ultimately to find a
reason to split Fink's and Nobunaga at
the end of the chapter creating a strain
on the troop Dynamic so that Nobunaga
would be more inclined to have some fun
deadly adventures with new best friend
Henry it's just like the meme friendship
ended with Finks now Henry is my best
friend also thinks Nobunaga arguing
about nen just just gonna put this out
there but it sounds exactly like every
nen speculation Reddit thread that I've
ever seen and I love it before we move
on I just want to express my general
appreciation for feitan as always he had
a couple of really great moments in 398.
I especially enjoyed every time he like
wiggled his sword to get the victims to
do something and also the commentary of
like don't get him started because he
rarely stops after cutting off the ears
which is also kind of shocking directly
juxtaposed against the sarasa events
that we just saw to think that after
everything that happened to her feitan
basically became one of those torturers
to shopping people up those videos
definitely taught him a lot now as for
the plan going forward I think that some
people were a bit shocked by the sheer
recklessness of Henry's actions not only
willingly stepping into the Trap but
also handing what could be his life's
Final Act to the Phantom troop people
that he had never met up until now and
had no real reason to trust I think it
makes sense though because Henry
understands exactly how desperate the
situation is they can't just keep taking
that time and feeding more underlings to
the Haley family making them stronger
and stronger like Morena needs to be
stopped right here and now because every
minute that goes by they become more
powerful more experienced they talk talk
to each other they have ideas so Henry
is volunteering to quite possibly die in
the Trap so that he can sick the
Calamity that is the Phantom troop
directly on Morena and I don't think
this is particularly surprising either
because the Gu Family does seem to
operate with a very strong sense of
loyalty and always working towards the
greater Prosperity like Misha the woman
who died but left behind the post-mortem
nen zombie girl ability also I just want
to say that I have never identified with
a troop member stronger than I did with
Nobunaga in this chapter when Henry
turned that transmitter into an oyster I
I physically recoiled I I despise
Seafood especially anything raw now with
that out of the way everything else
Henry did impressed the crap out of me
he saw what needed to be done and then
he did the thing it is that he saw plus
this might be a bit overlooked but as
soon as he got teleported he immediately
turned around and dropped to the floor
which was almost certainly a funky
maneuver performed to avoid being
attacked which is exactly what we saw
happening to that one guy who was killed
from behind after he got teleported
trying to retrieve his shiv why did did
you do that guy were you not paying
attention or you weren't you weren't and
now you're dead but it's small stuff
like that that shows Henry's experience
so even if he did walk into the same
trap he would have had a Fighting Chance
of surviving very unfortunately for
Henry the Haley family are currently
that one step ahead and the only thing
that can now potentially save Henry is
the new best Bromance in the series
after going and kill our heartbreakingly
split up Nobunaga and Henry is a very
welcome combination with Nobunaga taking
quite the liking to Henry even asking
for his name and just saying no no call
me Nobunaga drop the honorifics bruh it
almost gives me the feeling that Henry
is being auditioned as a potential troop
member and he does right now have an
ability that they so sorely lack which
is general information gathering but I
do think that Henry is probably a bit
too married to the jiyu family and the
whole Mafia thing unless the family was
completely wiped out that could be a
thing but even then he would join the
troop just to get killed by hisoka
speaking of that's a connection we
probably shouldn't forget Henry
theoretically knows where hisoka is most
of that knowing does depend on on
whether or not hisoka actually did the
thing that Henry proposed and I don't
know how confident I am with hisoka
following instructions but our situation
here could be where that key information
gets passed on to the troop provided
that Nobunaga and Henry don't pass on
first which well to be honest I feel is
very possible right now maybe it's just
the atmosphere of like the room that was
created but the end of the chapter had
me extremely tense because we're dealing
with two characters who aren't strictly
speaking absolutely integral to the
progression of the story one or both of
them could absolutely die here and the
room itself is just terrifying I love
and hate the atmosphere of it at the
same time it gives me some really filthy
gruesome saw Vibes which given all of
the murdering that's happened in there
is is probably understandable but the
room itself also has this like very
Twisted sense of humor if you look
carefully you'll notice there's a poster
on the wall of the fly which given all
of the teleportation powers in play is
like disgustingly appropriate but also
they've gone to the trouble to segregate
the bathrooms by gender however the way
in which they've done that is by writing
the symbols on what looks to be just an
excessive amount of blood like we didn't
need that much blood this would have
been fine instead it's like smear but
look at someone who used to design for
theater this set or this stage as nobody
calls it is perfect because the location
itself creates an incredibly unsettling
feeling and in case you're wondering
that room that this chapter leaves us on
the Cliffhanger is one that we've seen
before it's the corpse disposal room
from chapter 394 where the dead guy gets
cut up by the overly enthusiastic
dissection sisters so barring any more
teleportation Shenanigans at the very
least what nubunaga and Henry are going
to discover is going to be unpleasant
however back to the initial room itself
it's also very disconcerting because it
appears to have been created by Aura
Nobunaga can't even cut through the
walls indicating that their conjure
transmuted or even worse something
specialized however I would say that the
Occam's razor solution is that the room
was conjured particularly because it's
not the most complicated feat in the
world to perform and there was also this
one offline by gelato in a previous
chapter that there seemed to be a lot of
left-handed conjurers implying that the
Hailey family have something of a
conjure a surplus happening the only
thing that gives me pause for thought is
that one like stupidly disturbing panel
of Morana this image legitimately gives
me chills I hate looking at it because
it was inserted so ominously why is it
there what is it implying is it implying
that Miranda is currently watching
Nobunaga and Henry or is it implying
that this whole room is mirena's
fabrication which I will say would make
some sense she is the game master after
all so it's very in keeping with that
Motif that she would also be the one
creating the dungeons for the players
but that smile she has is simply
disturbing like she is toying with
Nobunaga and Henry and again to be fair
they they have just walked right into
her trap the Hailey family for the first
time in this conflict are currently at
least one step ahead here and I'm
definitely nowhere near as confident
about her and then veteran surviving
here as I was in the outside world
because now the Haley family have the
numbers they also have the information
because they've seen both Henry and
Nobunaga at work and in addition to that
they have complete control of the
environment and the sad irony of either
nobunagara or Henry dying here is that
they would be destined to end up just
like sarasa so there's an irony for
Nobunaga there if either he or his new
best friend were to suffer that same
fate here's a brief glimpse into the
future now if you're unaware tagashi
went on a bit of a Twitter spree posting
cryptic pictures of his manuscripts and
what I will say for the scribbles that
we've seen of chapter 399 is that it
looks like some stuff's about to go down
also I have a massive spoiler confirmed
for chapter 400 which I'll tell you
about in a bit but first togashi's
author comment this week gave us some
massive news staff member Tana Hana here
the chapters running right now and the
next 30 were all written four years ago
so I want to show you what we are
drawing right now and then it gets cut
off but this is confirmed that there are
indeed at least 30 more chapters in the
works with that said I wouldn't expect
them all at once they'd be more likely
to be released in batches with breaks in
between maybe a couple of months but
still this this is better news than I
ever could have have dreamed of and also
here is something huge that we've known
about for a while now if you keep up
with the Togashi news but it's becoming
very relevant now but Togashi on Twitter
did confirm that chapter 400 is when we
will finally see The Return of karapika
because tagashi quite blatantly posted
his full karapika sketch from the
chapter the reason why I bring that up
is because we're at 398 and that's 400
so it looks like we're going to be
switching things up real soon
potentially moving away from the mafia
stuff and back to all of the Tier 1
Prince business and what that means for
Nobunaga and Henry is either that we
could be left on a massive Cliffhanger
regarding their Fates or in the worst
case scenario both of their stories
could be very suddenly wrapped up in the
next two chapters